con todos los ojos puestos en la nueva
administración estadounidense el
presidente nicolás maduro quiso
aprovechar el giro político en
washington el mandatario venezolano dijo
que está dispuesto a pasar la página y
establecer nuevas relaciones con la
administración de joe biden una promesa
que repitió el sábado frente a una
multitud en que hace dos años
reaccionamos al intervencionismo
golpista de trump
hoy decimos venezuela esta venezuela del
siglo 21 bolivariana y revolucionaria
está dispuesta a pasar la página y a
construir nuevos caminos de respeto
diálogo y comunicación diplomática con
el nuevo el gobierno de eeuu pero las
intenciones de maduro bien podrían
chocar con la realidad a pesar del
cambio de gobierno pensando en la
audiencia de confirmación en el senado
estadounidense anthony blinken el
nominado de bailén para el secretario de
estado dijo que no apoyaría el régimen
de maduro y que como muchos otros países
eeuu planea seguir reconociendo el líder
opositor juan guaidó un renovado apoyo
que ha sido bienvenido por wide o tras
la técnica perdida de su rol en la
asamblea nacional tras una elección que
fue boicoteada por la oposición
venezolana y en la que el chavismo
reclamó una arrasadora victoria westling
quien denominó a nicolás maduro en el
pasado como un brutal dictador y
analistas de la política externa de eeuu
afirman que la administración baiden
probablemente volverá a la mediación
internacional para forzar una transición
en el poder en venezuela un potencial
próximo capítulo
no será del agrado de nicolás maduro